[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es eine ganz einfache
himbeer mascarpone torte mit einem nuss
und schokoladen bist wird die torte ist
wirklich in der herstellung super
einfach und das ist einfach mal eine
torte die jetzt zum einen aus eurem
fahrrad machen könnt weil ich dafür
nämlich tief gefrorene früchte verwendet
und alles andere habe ich normalerweise
immer in meinem wachs schrank oder in
meinem kühlschrank und die torte ist
wirklich sehr schnell gemacht ist
supereinfach und sie ist auch super
lecker und ich starte jetzt direkt mit
dem usb stick für den disput verwende
ich vier eier 100 gramm zucker eine
prise salz etwas vanille extrakt und
einen heißen espresso 100 gramm herren
schokolade 125 gramm haselnüsse und 50
gramm mehl nämlich zuerst die eier die
kommen ihnen die rührschüssel dazu etwas
vanille extrakt
den heißen espresso der sorgt dafür dass
sich die eier gut aufschlagen lassen
salz und zucker und werden ist es und
ich möchte kann auch einfach heißes
wasser nehmen und jetzt die zutaten für
etwa 5 minuten schaumig rühren und in
der zwischenzeit der ofen ist jetzt auch
vorgeheizt und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal die haselnüsse und
schokolade fein mahlen
[Musik]
kommen die trockenen zutaten mit zwei
asse also haselnüsse die schokolade und
die zutaten werden jetzt nur ganz kurz
untergehoben
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier bereits einen
tortenring einschlagen in backpapier
[Musik]
hier fühle ich jetzt erst wird ein
und dann kann ich ihnen direkt backen
und nach dem backen lasse ich den bizkit
abkühlt und dann ist schon direkte creme
an der reihe
[Musik]
für die creme wendig 500 gramm
mascarpone 100 gramm butter zucker 250
milliliter sahne etwas salat vanille
extrakt und zitronen abrede ich nehme es
erst die mascarpone die konten der
rührschüssel da kommt der puderzucker
dazu dann ein bisschen vanille extrakt
und dann kann ich die mascarpone erst
einmal glatt verrühren
kommt hier etwas zu tun und abrieb boxen
und dann müsste einfach nur darauf
achten dass die zitrone unbehandelt ist
ich gebe jetzt nur eine kleine prise das
so soll er keine zitronen und horte
retten aber wenn ihr den
zitronengeschmack intensiver haben
möchtet könnt ihr auch den abtrieb und
da ganz ohne dazu geben jetzt die saale
dazu ganz langsam dazugießen und dann
nehme ich jetzt das sommerbad als sammel
stand mitte und schlagt die greenstein
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt den
abgekühlten kuchen auch noch trinken
mit etwas espresso oder likör zum
beispiel amaretto wird jetzt ganz gut
dazu passen ja was so ein bisschen
darüber träufeln
und wer möchte kann natürlich auch den
tortenboden aufschneiden und in der
mitte noch füllen mit mascarpone creme
ich lasse es jetzt aber so da kommt
jetzt die mascarpone creme drauf
dann einfach schön glatt streichen
[Musik]
jetzt steht hier das daran so ein
bisschen verschmiert ist und ich mache
gleich noch die hinweg ich drauf und die
soll auch schön glatt auflegen jetzt
nehme ich einfach einem teig habe gehe
hier am rand entlang und dann mit der
band wird das schön sauber und die torte
sich später schön sauber ist da kann ich
die torte kurz künste und nehmen wir
zwischenzeitlich in der masse zu bringen
würde ich ihn besser verwende ich 350 mm
saft eine halb päckchen arriaga 20 gramm
zucker und etwa 400 gramm tiefgefrorene
hin werden ich nehme jetzt zuerst den
saft da hab ich jetzt einfach im roten
was habe ich da wohl viel vitamin d
multivitamin habe ich nicht geschafft
für kirschsaft und da gebe ich jetzt
agger dazu und es gibt an
unterschiedlichen agata und magazine und
zwar schaut ihr da einfach mal auf der
verpackung da steht nämlich auf der
rückseite wie viel gramm für wie viele
mittel nicht ausreichen und ich habe
jetzt hier einfach die himbeeren und den
sachs zusammengezählt bisschen also etwa
750 und die himbeeren lassen ja auch
wasser weise gefroren sind und daher
benutze ich da auch die menge an
geliermittel die ich eben benötigt hier
noch den zucker mit rein und dann die
masse aufkochen lassen um mindestens
zwei minuten lang sprudeln lassen damit
dass agrana auch studieren kann
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach die
menge von der himbeere also die 400
gramm und die 350 meter sagt
zusammengezählt das in der 750 und
dementsprechend dann einfach das agatha
verwendet und das sind in dem fall eben
einen halb päckchen
[Musik]
wer sichergehen möchte ob die masse
verliert gibt jetzt einfach einen
teelöffel auf einen teller dann kurz in
den kühlschrank und dann könnte er
innerhalb von einer minute ungefähr
sehen ob die masse fest wird ich nehme
ist die gefrorenen heben werden und gibt
sich hier mit rein
das hat natürlich den vorteil dass die
masse gleich abkühlt und ich sehe direkt
auf die torte geben kann
das müsst ihr nur schnell arbeiten damit
sie nicht im topf schon geliert
[Musik]
schön verteilen und dann direkt auf die
torte das ist schon okay jetzt kann ja
mal passieren
ist da was das ist jetzt gar nicht
schlimm ist das jetzt einfach machen
ich mache jetzt einfach noch mal
tortenguss also noch mal 250 meter mit
nem halben packs und aka aka und geht
jetzt einfach hier trinken die
tiefgefrorenen himbeeren einfach noch zu
kalt
hierzu stehen machst du heute schon fest
aber es kann immer passieren also macht
ihr am besten nur die hälfte dahin
bernrain und die hälfte dahin wenn
direkt auf die torte und ich mache es
noch ein paar staaten gus soviel dazu
sally gelingt bei der immer alles
die zweite menge noch gekocht und die
gebe ich jetzt hier einfach ganz
vorsichtig darüber
und ich schreibe euch auf dem blog dann
einfach die menge die ich jetzt hier
auch noch benutzt habe das hat die
gesamte menge unter menschen verteilt er
einfach ein paar himbeeren auf dem
tortenboden auf der creme und die
restlichen hin werden dann so zum
bisschen runterkühlen vom acker und dann
passt das ganze auch wunderbar okay sie
zwar okay aus aber irgendwie gefällt sie
mir nicht ganz
ich glaube ich kann das noch besser
kommen spiele jetzt einfach noch mal
zurück
ich habe weil sich hier jetzt diese
schön glatt gestrichene torte ich habe
hier die gefrorenen himbeeren und hab
den saft mit dem agatha und zucker zwei
minuten lang sport und aufkochen lassen
den nehme ich jetzt hier mit drüber und
jetzt nämlich die meisten himbeeren und
geht es dann schon mal direkt auf die
torten oberfläche
[Musik]
und ein paar wenige in bern habe ich
jetzt hier übrig die kommen jetzt in die
ada masse dadurch kann ich sie ein
bisschen runterkühlen und dann über die
kindern darüber geben und dann die
tische in kühl stellen
also jetzt nicht den fehler machen und
zu heiß drauf
[Musik]
jetzt die abgründe torte direkt auf eine
tortenplatte und dafür habe ich jetzt
den toten retter schnell fährt einfach
das back-office umschlagen und runter
wegrollen
und dann erst den ring entfernt
[Musik]
orad tv wir ja immer coole schon aus
graz das ist jetzt nicht sauber gemacht
egal ich mich normalerweise eines
messers an bord damit die samen nicht
schlimm ist schon für mich ich bin ich
viele wichtige person für die fotos
machen ach so war ärgerlich und die sind
aber cool aus ja und wie dieser schmeckt
dann halte ich das okay für sie ist
nicht so wie ich es mal so ich mache
kriegen den rand immer so für die fotos
selber da hast du mir vorher nicht ruhig
die gedanken kein photoshop das ist
immer unter schock
die tote stadt echt super easy zu machen
beachtet er schmeckt ich weiß noch die
neue kindes bleibt gar nicht mehr kennen
doch den sinkflug joghurt ja das hast du
schon mal gesagt wenn der tod der jungen
frau gesagt aber er schmeckt nach
flugdauer lustig lustig und schokolade
und oben ding also und vor allem ist
auch zu wenig ja und in zukunft
reduzieren ich bin nämlich gar nicht süß
ja bring dein himmel an weil ich hier
immer so säuerlich passenden zucker ich
will was schmeckt der kaffee im boden
ganz gut raus und wer also keinen kaffee
markt nimmt am besten league oder den
saft oder lässt effekt kuchen ist auch
so saftig genug sodass ich ehrlich sagen
schmecken kann mich ja ich habe ich zwei
nachträglich magnus manske oder bei mir
weggedrängt als beginnen ja auch echt
gut und vor allem super einfach nur
macht er wirklich alles in einen
tortenring ohne den tortenring zu
entfernen
man hatte arbeitszeit so ungefähr eine
halbe stunde vielleicht die kühnheit
noch dazwischen und da hat man wirklich
super schnell so eine torte für die
kaffeetafel gegangen weil sie das was
jetzt nachbacken wollt geht aufs
erlebnis glaubt ihr könnt natürlich auch
oben drauf andere früchte verwenden
erdbeeren oder da gibt es doch auch
diese exotische mischung im tiefkühlfach
diese mango und so weiter können die
auch bemerkung also wenn er sagt ich
kann den becher und falls ihr das noch
machen wollt wie gesagt zum nachlesen
auf zehn.de arriva nicht so süß und bis
zum nächsten mal
da kann man nur zwei stücke ist einfach
mal wieder was einfach ein paar einfach
sollten uns bringt besucher
[Musik]